mark when you meet with the producer or
you get an email or a phone call and
they're saying we want to do this movie
and they just give you just a little bit
less than a paragraph of information
what is that like for you to create this
outline and then go to pages on that
it's terrifying no no it is because many
times they have which I like a definite
idea because they have a buyer or they
have a network that's already signed off
which is called green you know greenlit
movie it's already signed off on the
concept they just need to see a script
that they can say oh I see what you're
doing and a few sometimes it's two
sentences it's a pitch then I have to
come back and and and create an outline
like we're talking about maybe 10 12
pages of a story you know the treatment
that's a lot more work obviously then
sometimes when they give me a one sheet
which is one sheet of paper which is a
synopsis and usually the middle is kind
of vague and there is an ending point
which you okay this is how it wraps but
even that sometimes is vague there's
there's beats that are skipped and so um
so that I have to come up with the exact
specific detail way of how the movie
ends not like just in generalities like
well you know blah blah and then they
end up in jail and the other person's
this you know so which is okay because
I'm living with it I'm not just taking
it and you know I mean it's it's it's
now it becomes that's why I saw an
interview and someone said well it's
different than spec writing assignment
writing and it is because it's not your
baby but it is your baby it becomes your
baby it's the adopted child you know
that you love because now it's your job
and you better love it because why are
you doing the job you know I mean okay
you can do it for money but if you're
pounding away going I hate this it's
gonna show you know and so you know
everything shut down and saying this is
it becomes yours even sometimes the the
the rewrite jobs become yours I think
because you're rewriting in your own
style and voice and fixing things and
and you know they how much is the old
writers and how much is yours and you
if it's 50/50 who knows what you know
you could sit down and say in that scene
I did you know when I'm watching it I
can tell you exactly that lines mine
that's not and that's when they came in
and did that that's me that's you know I
mean that's going through your head
almost like a crazy person watching
about you know but so that that's at
least in my experience that's how it's
worked either it's a it's a pitch that
you know pitch me and I pitch me I've
pitched them I've also come to them with
the one sheet but you know many times
that's like Oh interesting but they they
already know what their buyers want I
don't so it's a lot easier for them to
come to me and say we need this you're
like okay you know what I mean so but
like you said it takes up for me about
two weeks of solid work to get the
treatment and then that's rewritten
before I'm allowed to go to the
screenplay
you